why are you so confident he'll change
his behavior mr president
yeah i'm not confident hey what are you
doing
you don't understand that you're in your
own business wow
this is why joe biden ran for president
wow guys the media are just in the bag
for biden
as always this whole thing was not
directed for foreign consumption
it was not directed at accomplishing
anything it was directed toward american
consumption
that's all it was directed at an
american political audience
because biden knew that if he said a
couple of things like human rights and
democracy without actually demanding
anything of putin in terms of hard
deliverables
then the media would celebrate him and
say well at least he isn't trump and
that's exactly
what he got because this is our media
does that mean meanwhile i mean
it is incredible the media are being
treated just as just what they are they
are lap dogs biden pats them on the head
every so often
and he puts them outside when they are
being unpleasant they start barking he
immediately takes them and he pushes
them into the yard
and they they're just fine with it it's
absolutely incredible
so there was a clip that went viral a
little bit yesterday these reporters
who are outside their mics were on and
uh they started joking about the kinds
of questions that they were going to be
asking
biden right before the summit
what did you think of the vice
president's
what are the questions they're joking
about where's hunter when is kamala
harris going to the border
and then and they're joking about that
because they know that they're never
going to ask a difficult question of joe
biden
right they're they're literally joking
about wouldn't be ridiculous if we asked
why kamala harris isn't going to the
border it's just amazing meanwhile joe
biden
is treating the media exactly as they
wish to be treated in this bizarre s m
relationship
joe biden is he he's literally going
into press conferences and just reading
the stage directions
he's like they gave me a list of people
and i should call on because i don't
know faces
anymore or where i am there was the
president of the united states yesterday
in geneva
this is not about just our self-interest
it's about a mutual self-interest
i'll take your questions and as usual
folks they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so uh
jonathan associated press
okay they gave me a list who is they
aren't you the most powerful man on
planet earth
who is they they gave you a list my
goodness
his handlers my goodness okay and then
he had this bizarre sort of exchange
with cnn's caitlyn collins the way the
media treated this exchange
is really really telling so here was joe
biden yelling at cnn's caitlyn collins
like yelling at her
here we go why are you so confident
he'll change his behavior mr president
yeah i'm not confident hey what are you
doing
so when did i say i was confident
what i said was let's get it straight i
said what will
change their behavior is the rest of the
world reacts to them and it diminishes
their standing in the world i'm not
confident of anything
i'm just stating the fact so how does
that account to a
constructive meeting as a president
president putin you don't understand
that you're in your own business
if you don't understand that in the
wrong business now imagine that
president trump has said that to a
reporter a female reporter imagine that
a female reporter called out to him
and he had walked back and then started
chiding her and then finished with
you don't understand your own business
we would get a three week long news
cycle
about sexism the vicious brutal sexism
of that exchange we would get a long
news cycle about attacks on a free press
oh my god over threat
jim acosta would just be slobbering all
over himself as per his usual
arrangement
instead here's how cnn covered that
exchange okay remember caitlyn collins
is a reporter for cnn here's how cnn
covered
that exchange wolf it is quite
striking to just see the confidence in
his approach in his tone
as he really handles all of this he did
not go point by point
rebutting everything that vladimir putin
said there was a discussion among white
house aides what he
should talk about but in the end he
ended up talking about this press
conference essentially what he had
planned to going into it
he you know certainly was comfortable
in that moment taking off his jacket uh
answering these questions from some top
foreign policy reporters
in the audience that he doesn't always
call on
wolf as we assess this trip
this is why joe biden ran for president
unbelievable i mean first of all i
thought that cnn had originally
suspended jeffrey tubin from
masturbating on camera but
apparently you're allowed to do it so
long as so long as they let you
and it's um wow
wow guys so you have the president of
the united states attack your own
reporter
and you're too busy fapping to uh to
actually say a damn word about it well
done cnn by the way even biden later
recognized there was some blow back
online and biden was like
probably i should probably walk that
back a little bit so here's the truth is
joe biden is a combative jerk
okay people who have been following him
in the media for years know this he
treats the media like this
right he's very combat you saw on the
campaign trail he literally called the
guy fat on the campaign trail when the
guy asked him a tough question he's like
listen up
fat remember that one that is actually
who joe biden is he's not this genteel
elderly statesman he's an idiot he's
been an idiot for 40 years
he's a loudmouth braggart dumbass and
and like the the fact that we treat our
politicians this way is truly incredible
to me and the fact that the media treat
the politicians
who who like they only like them when
they get what they want from the media
obviously
my favorite tweet of yesterday there was
a there's a journalist and i'm trying to
remember which one
who tweeted yesterday joe biden just
said that journalists are the smartest
people he knows
donald trump never said anything like
that yeah cause it's not true
journalists are not the smartest people
i know are you out of your mind i work
with journalists every day
some of them are smart some that are
some of them are dumb as rocks
the hell are you talking about the
smartest people i know are
mathematicians
doctors phds in actual hard sciences not
like in education
like what what but the media are like oh
my god
oh it's like when harry met sally out
here for the media oh he said we're
smart oh
oh oh i'll have what they're having and
what in the what in the actual world so
here is joe biden walking that back he
knows where his bread is buttered too
which is as long as he continues to
massage the media every so often they
will continue to uh
to release his chakras
look to be a good reporter you got to be
negative you got to have a negative view
of life okay it seems to me
the way you all you never ask the
positive question why in fact
having agreement we'll find out the
thing that always amazed me about the
questions
and i apologize for having been short
done before
if you were in my position would you say
well i don't think man anything's going
to happen it's going to be really rough
i think it's going to really be bad you
guarantee nothing happens
okay first of all it's the stupidest
answer i've ever heard no you should be
honest you should say
i am highly skeptical that we are going
to get any sort of
concession from the russian government
absent serious international pressure
which is why i'm calling for a
ratcheting up of serious international
pressure
instead it's like i'm hopeful that we'll
get something yeah good luck with that
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video